you
already created tournaments 52 players
at the kickoff
thirty minutes of one minute chess
d for a C for a slob
ok so no Bishop move
let's take once let's get this light
squared bishop off he's a really strong
piece
stop the night jump sneak in a flight
square take and maybe I push here you
know maybe I push and then put my knight
on c6 I like this idea he could be very
disruptive should be very disruptive
on the rook okay so they really didn't
like that so I want to pile up on that
yeah let's take them centralized did I
miss an opportunity for okay let's run
out like this I should just be winning
this pawn
here give
and then drop back covering everything
and this force is the queen exchange so
otherwise I have this I could have just
taken the knife for free actually
okay that is with check and drop that
guy I guess okay let's just stay
defended target this pawn next
everything's defended you have a check
and that is actually made they resigned
though okay Lu
I see the Ferrari uh he's so fast he was
only there for a second then he's gone
that's how fast the Ferrari is okay a
long time
Ferrari where has the Ferrari been I
wonder if the Ferrari knows that I get
comments like that on YouTube there's
always those who question you know what
you know who hasn't been around the
Ferrari oh I see him
Oh getting upon
let's do this just to break this up just
to break stuff up
and put pressure on them now that's the
idea make them weak and then and then
attack them
I guess we'll go here the rook is gonna
get a little active it could have gotten
a little active so now we're gonna get
fancy a lot of pieces on light squares
so just put them on a safe Square and
improve the King from here everything's
glued together pretty much even trades
that's all I want
enter with the King a little bit improve
with the King
here here
and run the phones
no stalemates
here we go back to tournament land the
Ferrari
is berserk I see
okay I wasn't the only nm as well that I
saw some other nm that jumped in
great great to see I'm going fishing
it's been a while oh I'm on that pun why
why does every move kind of feel like
it's a it's a surprise oh you'd really
didn't know that fishing we're just
going fishing okay we're getting the
dark square bishop so make sure ya nm
unicorns I'm seeing it now someone in
the chat D web is pointing this out
alright let's play here I'm giving this
square up but I have something fancy
let's take here first cuz now I'm
getting the Queen it's one less piece
the knight isn't there that's check and
now it's Domino's damn in no time they
all start to fall one by one
and forks
then go after the king they resigned
back to tournament land
okay
Ferrari has now
taking his foot off the gas all right
same opponent from round one let's
establish upon on d5
mission accomplished okay they're going
for a fee and cut out sneak in a flight
square
let's just keep the structure as is I
don't want to have to take like this and
then fight like crazy for the c5 square
let's put some pressure here that night
double No so what's their bishop doing
any fancy tactics I don't see him no
let's sneak in here she can rely upon
that square mm-hmm but we go here and
getting some some material I'm up I have
pressure on the night so
they didn't see that
he resigned back determined
okay yeah I'm not sure about the it's
definitely not the most testing line to
Fein Qaeda the bishop with an exchange
Slav because my e6 d5 structures kind of
goes unchanged and okay here we go got a
shut up got the Ferrari going berserk
town
going berserk town
stop b5 so fast
knows this system so well and plays it
plays it a lot
breakin open here so quick fast and
furious it's actually difficult to
defend let's go here hmm
let's drop back well I was Nina why
wasn't I moving there
what's that about I have enough on that
MSR just miscalculated
okay let's get my knight out of harm's
way
and pick some stuff up
soon I have coordination all right the
Ferrari goes down but I was I was
getting berserk there all right 22 just
under 22 and here 87 are now in here so
a lot of you came out for this one very
nice did not want to play in the themed
tournament even though I'm a fan of the
CARICOM all Rygaard
so maybe we switched to e4 pretty
symmetrical
okay the Queen's are gone let's preserve
the light square bishop
one step back I jump in soon I think now
why did I go here another naked post
with a punch let's try this
I'm just getting trapped Hope Chest this
is night needs to do something else he's
he's negated by that pawn
oh that kind of capture huh let's try
this and then here and now I kind of
want to close now I want to keep this
tension maybe
I'll take and then connect rooks Bishop
takes on playing f6 in my king of
campout on f7 actually you know what
their Bishop can't move otherwise they
lose this pawn so I'm gonna try and do
some stuff over here why they give me
this file
they are down on time just try to get
active
oh my goodness that's a look what I
found move realize it was me I I feel
like a let's just insert a check
killer bishops man scissors on the old
crisscross there all right oh that's
always a nice surprise right oh I didn't
what did I say about playing d4 let's
let's not put my bad bishop outside the
pawn chain what variety
oh okay let's hunt
let's go hunting
okay I don't want to move my structure
can I say push I jump in here
all right let's make use of this gap
the night's gonna go here very nice very
nice
I see let's just grab some space I got I
have to offset that night my bishop is
stupid
so what's the plan it's to go here
that's how we're gonna get him out there
we go
gonner next phase get rid of their night
why why why do I want to do that I have
a square to work with as well let's get
back here let's try it again
hmm let's let's keep the night under
control okay I want to get rid of him
they're gonna play g5 or are they
I'll try and slow it down I have space
over here so I just want to control the
kingside if I can okay
if you play g5 I have something to do
much time how much time
yeah just go one square Fonz can move
two squares dummy
you dummy
gotta go faster close shop over here's
where the action is go King it's
important
sneaky pawn it's completely locked
sneaky pawn again what [ __ ] no position
neither of us could win
that final position what's the plan in
that final position don't capture if you
can capture just don't capture and it's
a drum that's a way to never I'm playing
this again okay I'm capturing with the
pond just to make it a little different
[Laughter]
oh man
this isn't this isn't such a bad pun
this is turning out pretty well actually
well they doing about b7 we're coming
for you mmm here's the plan here's the
plan hmm
oh I could take and then go here the
rook is unprotected now I get b5 in
let's take
of now
to a ball let's try this maneuver Oh
they're giving me a file activated my
rook in a very awkward way but it seems
to be working
seems to ones one step only get to the
seventh uh-huh okay let's let's make
some progress over here now now that
they're in a pickle these are like that
pre move right there I can't take set
for just the case the the black pawn
takes here let's get in playing okay
look I'm around here now I'll get the
break in improve it the King provoke
some weaknesses infiltrate
I'm ready to get a fork
you
I went time Berner land towards the end
okay wow this is flying by only only 15
minutes left 97 are in here Ferrari has
yeah he slipped up some he's got 19
Popovic eform is ready to d4 again
we have a caro-kann land
the upper get rid of the dark square
bishop
I wouldn't mind getting the Queen's off
my knight should be pretty good right
here
last castle
I put my knight on a nice square I don't
know how safe their King is
how safe is their king my King needs to
go somewhere else I think this is where
he belongs
a shoe that Bishop away
gotta go somewhere else let's try this
want to get it there King open up the
center
we make this happen we're gonna try
thirty two ticker oneís sake with the
rook here we go we got some lateral
moving B 5 B 4 I'm coming for you we got
him what to do next
challenge that King position whoa that's
a free rook back determine I almost miss
that bishops go backwards sometimes easy
to miss 32 with fire 13 and change
remaining 99 are now in here the captain
is 10 out
okay um II five play like alpha zero
let's see how this works
alpha wouldn't do that
okay so they can't really annoy me with
the pin but I could uh I could try to be
annoying to team white gonna save that
Bishop no I don't care enough about him
they just don't care
secure the night and be happy that we
have a flight square prepare to throw
the F on in the mix on d3 I caused some
chaos let's try you could get trapped
he's he's almost trapped
okay I can rely upon this square and
chased around a little bit but I got the
I got the killer bishops take with the
clean watch out
my knight needs to land a fork very soon
I should have um I should have got my
rook active first and have the rooks
come off let's go here and then here
here and then here everybody should try
that at least once here and then here oh
boy it's it's looking very scary now
very scary
what's that about I'm getting upon you
after all that I'm getting upon and now
my rook turns into Pac Man their pawns
are very weak let's go hunting
the rook can't move there's a cost if he
moves my rook is sneaky
let's check check it's almost me
I got everything defended
careful now
you
I don't want to end up in stalemate
don't stalemate him Oh like it could
have been still made some mistake Mike
weed that way she's not controlling all
your squares that's all I was thinking
take my queen take her I'll get another
one later when I know it's not stalemate
okay dark-squared bishop scan we've got
a challenge these guys they're tough
isolated pawn position isolated pawns
open files let's keep him around
on a flight square I don't know oh I
know why I'm doing that I want to play
Queen d6
and not worry about not here though it
might have been okay just to provoke
something like that mmm let's try that
rook takes I have this and I went upon
though they get this at the end I'm
breaking up their structure
not really okay I'm gonna try to show
that this is a liability should be
hitting a lot of stuff right now hmm
giving me a pond let's go here I got the
a file if they take my queen
and hmm okay now I just I just take here
and then here and I do something really
passive but I have two connected passers
now I could I could give up one they
take one then I end up getting behind
the other and then this this should be
pretty clean
also have a time edge
at a time edge there is
dr. tournament land alright just under
no Queen Master Sun that was a very fast
pairing the captain is on my heels I'm
the only six back Exchange Cairo we've
been here before
I think we've played multiple games with
blitz time controls
so minority attack is is the plan I want
to be able to take the night when he
goes here so that's why I backed up so
I'm not in a fork
that's an idea oh yeah let's let's
follow through here it's here on the
pond they're giving me a pond and let's
offer a clean exchange again let's let's
go here
force the Queen's off whoa
let's go here she's not quite trapped
what am i doing
I just want to get stay coordinated
I want that clean off
this is the her
variation could I do something else I do
something else it's all I know how to do
offer a queen exchange this is not a
good recipe for success can we get the
Queens off okay I got a pawn at least
I could hit me with a fork was the night
dad he's dead
pigs okay start mopping up some ponds
now No
around for me
once let's do it like this
they're down on time oh my god every
Queen exchange that's all that game was
so how that game go between you and the
Queen Master it's amazing I offered a
queen exchange they declined like a
hundred times
Wow good job
brilliant brilliant plan and we're
taking with a pawn do I yeah I'll go
here thought they might pin um okay I
guess here I can't let's get this good
for bad bishop exchange in there
let's jump on up in there jump on up in
there beautiful keep the structure as is
he's poison if ever attacked by the
queen or the rook yeah a fancy stuff oh
they didn't see the fancy stuff let's
challenge the bishop my rooks want to
see other squares besides so they want
they want to see further we're getting
some stuff here d5 is collapsing at
least in-betweener
if Knight takes Knight my queen controls
this diagonal hold in-betweener incoming
I gotta move
they're still here am I getting Nonna
fright
oh you old fork the night had a
different idea in mind well it's just
pre-prepared to take the night if he
moves there down on time back determine
alright under five minutes
106 in here
11-point lead Ferrari did he's his game
just finish he's in a game against pehoe
vaq
I wonder what their scores okay queen
master again we're gonna have an
exchange Carol I'm fine with that
no an advanced and advanced Carol
let's operate on the
d5 square it's the first phase second
phase is to eventually break with okay
so this is excellent now it's excellent
let's see how they work around the night
mm-hmm
it just gave me a really good square for
the night oh I think they want to play
b3 they should challenge the night they
are could do this I don't really like
how I'm playing this one exactly but I
am getting a pawn now my bishop I want
to keep around to control this square
let's go here and I guess I'm going to
castle as much as I like having the rook
here let's start pushing this past pawn
keep pushing him get behind them
and
[Music]
about we we double up here here here I
could always have my Bishop defend g7
Queens I'm protected
let's push once more one step away now
let's take
I already go with the Queen exchange
Queen offer I want to get the Queen
reserved you drop my queen just then
we almost there
don't have much time
ah
you
I couldn't move Oh
two queens versus two pawns oh man
ah the Ferrari under two minutes so
close oh that's so painful two queens
versus two ponds no you never want to
lose like that
two queens versus two pawns never never
let that happen again huh
I have to do this so look what I found
move ah man I was trying to pre move I
couldn't pre move
ah men
okay let's say
they focused stay focused
he's too good gotta get rid of that
night
as the bishop
yeah Forks
okay
I just I want to run over here it's too
scary over there I just gave up that pun
I feel like I'm gonna get mated oh we
gotta run it like this I could take like
that I'm up a rope
okay
now stalemates man on stalemates
to terminal he stuck that lasted in
there GG queen master GG oh and that one
was very important actually just a hair
just by a hair
50 points 47 with Ferrari right on my
heels I didn't even I didn't realize Wow
okay 112 in all
50 47 40 fishy-fishy taking third phobic
right there as well nice turnout all
right let's check out all the pages
three four five six remind me tomorrow
what's that about
get out of here I'm trying to go through
the pages windows to the 111
good games off
you